thirty Mister secretary
can you please call the
roll Allen Archuleta
Atkins Bates they'll
gorgeous for coming era
Chiang dot
Dorado Galgiani
Glazer Grove Hertzberg
hill so our title
Jackson Jones Leyva
McGuire Mitchell
Monning Morlock
Morrell Nielsen pan
Portantino Roth Rubio
inner stern stone
number I Caskey winner
Wilk good
morning senators a quorum is
present with the members in
our gas beyond the rail and
in the gallery please rise
we're gonna be leading prayer
this morning buyer chaplain
sister Michelle Gorman after
which we're gonna ask that
all remain standing in the
lead in the pledge allegiance
to the flag by senator hill
let us center ourselves in god's
presence this is the prayer
of St Teresa of Avila
dear gods remember
this we are the plants in
your feels so connected
to the earth that do you
know what would happen if
you did nots rain upon us
and if your lights cease to
lift us from the ground and
craft our bodies how much
we come near you like the sons
please remember god's
to love us in a way
our souls can taste
and rejoice in a
man Korean
but it work but --
track of America
and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under
indivisible with liberty
and justice for all
members were dancing to
privileges of the floor
center Skinner has some very
special guests that she'd
like to be able to introduce
center Skinner will be
presenting at the proteins desk
the morning centers care
the floor is yours thank you
Mister president and colleagues
I invite you to join me in
welcoming a our delegation from
Canada each year a delegation
of Canadian diplomats visit
Sacramento to highlight the
importance of our Canadian and
California relationship the data
speaks clearly and convincingly
Canada's California's second
largest trading partner with
over forty five billion in
goods treated annually over
one point two million jobs
in California depend on the
trade and investment with
Canada California's visited
by over two million Canadians
every year who spend about one
point five billion in their
travels here maybe the most
fun statistic is that Canadians
by our winds they are the single
largest purchaser of California
wines with the average spending
of over four hundred million
every year now to celebrate this
vital relationship we welcome
consul general of Canada in
San Francisco Mister run us
our car who is participating
in its second day Canada day
here at the capitol Mister
Sarkar in his newly appointed
counterpart in Los Angeles
misters I. eve Sheik who is
unfortunately unable to join
us today were personally hand
picked by prime minister Trudeau
in recognition of the growing
importance of the California
can eight Canada relationship
in this moment of global change
both our new deployments that
diplomats skews me but not
new to diplomacy so they've
had they both had successful
careers in các global business
government and international
entertainment so Canada is one
of the world's most welcoming
destinations for immigration
more than one out of every
five Canadian residents are
foreign born in Canada is
often held up as a model for
how to craft smart immigration
policy and promote integrated
multi culturalism the Trudeau
government has committed
to diversity as a Canadian
strength with shared universal
values crucial to overcoming
barriers to inclusion in fact
making it a cornerstone of
Canada's economic strategy
the appointment of both these
council generals who come
from foreign born families
is a perfect example of this
approach today we take a moment
to recognize the significant
economic and cultural
relationships between our two
regions and we look forward to
our continued collaboration and
strengthening our long standing
behind so please join me in
extending a warm California
Senate welcome for Canadian
guess anything given in the
California State Senate that's
welcome some of our closest
allies in the Senate chambers
at this time we'd like to
welcome the Canadian delegation
in all interested senators to
be a to take a official photo
the back of the Senate chambers
I
members would like to turn
our attention back to center
Skinner to proteins desk thank
you -- colleagues I want to
welcome Albany girl scout
troop number three three nine
ninety in the gallery senators
give them a warm welcome
ladies and gentlemen of the
California State Senate it's
get the girl scout troop
our young women from this troops
are working with homeless folks
in our who live in their around
their area they've donated
items for them they've written
postcards to all of us hoping
that we will work on solutions
thank you girl scout troop
number thirty three ninety
thank you so much center Skinner
and we hope that they brought
samples of thin mints for every
member of the Senate today
we welcome you to the California
State Senate thank you
members without objection
we're going to move to Senate
third reading and focus on
SB one twenty six file item
number two senator Leyva
center labor is prepared to
take take this item up Mister
secretary can you please read
Senate bill one twenty six by
senator Leyva and actually to
charter schools center labor the
floor is yours thank you Mister
president good morning members
SB one twenty six ensures
that charter schools comply
with the same transparency
and accountability laws all
of our other public schools
currently follow as you know
the governor recently called for
swift action to resolve ongoing
charter school transparency
issues while charter schools
are unique in many ways they
are publicly funded and yet
they lack the same transparency
and accountability requirements
the governor other publicly
funded educational institutions
under this bill charter school
governing boards will be
required to comply with the
same open meeting conflict of
interest and disclosure laws as
traditional public school boards
this bill will also ensure
that members of charter school
governing boards cannot use
their positions for personal or
political game for several years
the legislature has attempted
to bring clarity to this
issue fortunately our Attorney
General recently published an
opinion clearly stating that
yes these good government laws
do apply to charter schools
while the attorney general's
opinion provides much needed
clarity on whether or not these
laws apply to charter school
governing boards the pin is
not legally binding absent the
measure before you today which
codifies the attorney general's
opinion disputes will continue
to happen across the state over
how these laws actually applied
to charter schools members
SB one twenty six reflects
our bicameral response to the
governor's call for action
this bill supported by teachers
school board members labor
and civil rights organizations
the California charter schools
association is neutral on this
bill I respectfully request an
aye vote thank you senator Leyva
members we're gonna open it up
for discussion or debate center
Glazer good morning Sir
thank you madam Mister president
and -- members aye aye rise also
in favor about this legislation
I want to thank the senator from
Chino -- her counterpart in the
assembly the assembly member
from Long Beach -- governor news
some -- and stakeholders who
worked hard on this issue over
the last a few weeks at this
is a -- an issue that center --
from Santa Monica and I worked
on for a number of years -- it
is true that -- charter schools
receive public dollars and they
should they should be under
obligation to provide the same
public disclosure open meeting
requirements that are other
schools that that are funded
by the public -- are -- must
undertake I would note a couple
things about this legislation
one is it does not provide an
exception to the rule on nine
conflict by allowing teachers
to participate in charter
school boards and I think
that's a healthy addition to --
governance we've done something
similar at our university system
by allowing faculty members
to serve on our governing
boards there but secondly --
that legislation has a point
of sensitivity in regard to
the charter schools that are on
tribal lands and I appreciate
the author's work to ensure that
we recognize the special status
of a of a charter school I
think there's just one on tribal
lands here in this space members
is been a lot of contentious
at ness and controversy
-- a lot of rhetoric
and -- I'm happy to see the
parties come together -- and
finding common ground on this
legislation I know that there
are other issues -- in this
space that continue to be points
of contention I appreciate
governor nuisance requested
the superintendent to form a
task force to deal with some of
the important issues regarding
-- charter schools in that
work will happen through the
course of this year it's my
hope that the work that we
do today the passage of this
legislation on the work that's
going to go -- on going with
the superintendent and the
governor will allow for some
level of peace to rein in our
land on these issues over the
course of the of this year --
and that this legislation is
a good start it's found common
ground it has a balance to it
and I hope that that can set
the right tone is the the author
said it during the committee
hearing set the right tone
after the year and I thank
her for her leadership on this
thank you thank you very
continue discussion or debate
will go first to senator more
lock and then to senator Allen
center more like the floor
is yours Sir good morning
thank you Mister president
I'd like to address SB
one twenty six from three
different perspectives at
the first is I believe in
no better and no worse if a
public school district board
must follow the requirements
elaborated in the bill and
charter schools should to
to California has nine hundred
and forty four school districts
a third of them as of June
thirty twenty seventeen have
been manage prudently reflecting
positive net unrestricted assets
the others are at various stages
of fiscal distress yes
seen recently with LA unified
school district teacher still
feel underpaid and thus under
appreciated and they would
still like to have more nurses
and counselors all good
requests understood but where
will the funding come from
obviously prop ninety eight is
not cutting it to the governor
and the legislature reposition
some of the twenty one billion
dollars surplus we're talking
about in our budget maybe
we could provide some help
for our schools on top of
the significant cal stirs
contribution that the governor's
proposing the fed the fiscal
strings are showing in this week
Oakland unified school district
is ready to go on strike
so third we're complaining
about a lot of things in in my
part of the state listening to
the news ever apparently that
the fall guy seems to be charter
schools everybody's pointing
at that a special committee
and I I I would I would I think
you have to look past a lot of
other culprits like pensions
and in the case of LA unified
school district retiree medical
liabilities they just published
their June thirty eight eighteen
comprehensive annual financial
report and had reflect fifteen
billion dollars of unfunded
retiree medical that's more than
twenty four thousand dollars per
student but more is a mess you
would not see charter schools at
school districts were providing
great education for students
appearance at every income
stratum parents were telling
us something is wrong and
they're voting with their feet
and they're waiting in long
lines to get into a charter
school so we are seeing a
symptom a bigger bigger concerns
Mister president consequently
tightening the screws on charter
schools may be a misdirected
an unfair legislative solution
the legislature needs to take a
hard look at the facts and not
come to the wrong conclusions
governor brown even started to
charter schools and supports
them in Oakland the smart money
in LA supports charter schools
maybe it's time to reevaluate
maybe this legislature should
really evaluate what we're
doing the prop ninety eight
with pension benefits going
forward with retiree medical
benefit formulas and with school
district funding allocations
that should make establishing
charter schools financially
seamless and a notice to their
budgets colleagues I want to
support a bill that addresses
the deep systematic currents
that are hurting our school
districts SB one twenty six is
a bandaid when major surgery
is needed thank you Mister
president center were locked
we're not gonna turn the Florida
senator Allen then we'll go
to senator Jackson center own
members I want to commend the
authors and I wanted to do
the associate myself with the
comments made by this center
from around at your behind
so many these bills is --
oftentimes incredible amount
of staff work and I just want
to take a moment having --
worked on this issue for quite
some time to recognize the
work of two very extraordinary
staffers whose whose work
underpinned several aspects
of this bill one of them from
my own personal staff Jennifer
chase and then from the
Education Committee staff -- in
Johnson is still there and work
with me very closely when I was
the education chair -- to really
extraordinary public servants
are staff of names are not out
of Klay recognized and so much
of their work is is present in
an in aspects of this bill --
there are to public servants
and I wanna recognize them
thank you Sir center Jackson
sorcerers thank you a miss
press in college I want to
return us back to what this
bill is not what it isn't --
and it's a very important bill
and I appreciate and know that
there's been a lot of hard work
done in this the bill's appeared
before the Senate Judiciary
Committee for a number of years
and efforts have been made to
really try to address what this
bill is all about it is about
transparency and accountability
so charter schools receive
enormous amount of taxpayer
dollars and their charge
with educating our children a
a responsible task in in a
reasonable one but there needs
to be sunshine in all publicly
funded schools and their
governing bodies and that is
what this bill calls for and I
am pleased that the California
Attorney General recently
published an opinion that was
consistent with the opinion of
our legislative counsel that our
state robots sunshine laws apply
to all charter schools that's
what this bill is about and it's
critically important because
the public is not only entitled
but they deserve to know where
our money is going and how it
is being spent particularly in
the pursuit of educating our
children so I am pleased that
this bill codifies once and
for all that the public records
act open meeting laws political
Reform Act and government codes
section ten ninety apply to
charter schools that is this
bill and with that I -- drive
vote for under discussion
or debate senator gorgeous
Mr resume idea pose a question
to the maker this agenda item
center Leyva we use up the
question from center board I
would love a question or just
please proceed thank you very
much -- I wanted to -- --
extend my appreciation for bring
this issue up for discussion
-- by -- by way of background
as an educator I do fully
appreciate -- the importance
of the brown act when it comes
to publicly funded institutions
I think it's important that
if -- if public institutions
on the traditional sense are
bound by the requirements of
the brown act -- so too should
charter schools in my opinion
so I I think that is very clear
in my opinion -- one of the
points brought up by one of my
colleagues is are we are we
imposing additional requirements
on charter schools by virtue of
this teleconference requirement
that don't that doesn't exist
with the traditional public
schools can you explain that
further I I certainly can't as
we as we talked earlier this
morning when you asked me the
same question I said the reason
we're doing that is because
with charter schools they may
have locations up and down the
state in in other areas within
the school district the schools
are with in that district so
many school districts move
the locations and the meetings
around so that's accessible for
everyone if I have a charter
school it's here in Sacramento
and I have another one that's
in Chino another one that's in
San Diego in order to make it
accessible for everyone having
the teleconference is a way
to let everyone participate
into in the interest of a
cost estimate for the new
teleconferencing requirements
the two way teleconferencing
for all of and I do not okay
-- were there any other --
committees that this would
normally be refer to that
were not in this instance I
have no idea why appear before
the committees that rule said
I need to appear before --
thank you very much thank you
members under discussion
or debate last call
discussion or debate on the
floor hearing you see nine
center Leyva would you like to
close please I would think you
are Mister president members
I think you those of you for
our your support on this bill
those who spoke in support I
appreciate the questions and
I did want to lay to rest some
of the issues that the senator
from Orange County brought up
-- this is a bill that is
not fiscal at all it's only
about transparency and it in
no way inhibits the growth
of charter schools members I
respectfully ask for an aye vote
Mister secretary can
you please call the roll
Allen hi Archuleta
I Atkins aye Bates
bell hi for just
by Bradford I can
be a real by Chiang
I Dodd I Dorado
aye Galgiani aye
Glazer aye growth
hi Hertzberg aye hill
aye Hueso by -- taught of
the five Jackson by Jones
nope Leyva
I am a choir aye Mitchell
aye Monning aye Morlock
Morrell no Nielsen
hi I pan aye
Portantino aye Roth aye Rubio
by Skinner aye stern
stone hi I'm Burke
I like husky by winner
by Wilk hi
Mr sector can you
please call the absent
members Bates by
more lock stern
ice thirty four nose to
the measure passes can we please
have immediate transmittal
of the bill to the assembly
members are now going to be
moving forward for messages
from the governor those will be
deemed read messages from the
assembly will be deemed read
have committee will be deemed
read and amendments adopted
under -- motions resolutions
and notices senators without
objection the Senate journals
for February nineteenth through
the twenty first two thousand
nineteen will be approved and
corrected by the minute clerk
senators were dancing to
introduction and first reading
of bills Mister sector can you
please read Senate bill four
seventeen four eighteen for
nineteen for twenty four twenty
one for twenty two four twenty
three thank you Mister secretary
bills we deem read we're not
gonna moving forward with the
consideration of the daily file
members removing with file item
number one Mister secretary
can you please read
assembly bill one forty nine
thank you so much Mr sack
during we're now moving on to
file item number three senator
Dodd are you prepared to take
up center dot is prepared to
take up Mister sector can you
please read Senate concurrent
resolution fourteen by senator
Dodd relative to eating
disorders awareness week good
morning center dot the floor is
yours Sir this president members
Essie our fourteen recognize the
week of February twenty fifth
two thousand nineteen to March
third two thousand nineteen as
eating disorders awareness week
in the United States thirty
million individual suffer
from clinically significant
eating disorders at some time
in their lives these disorders
affect men and women across all
backgrounds include anorexia
nervosa bulimia nervosa and
binge eating disorder colleagues
I gotta tell you I've seen first
hand how painful it difficult
these disorders can be I've had
a loved one who suffered from
an eating disorder I've also
seen that recovery is possible
so that is very very positive
-- in -- I join to a test
the importance of awareness
in understanding -- a strong
support network for those on a
journey to recovery as national
eating disorders awareness
week is a collaborative effort
by in the eating disorder
professionals healthcare
providers student educators
social workers in individuals to
raise awareness of the dangers
surrounding it eating disorders
and a critical need for early
intervention and treatment
access this resolution service
to further the conversation
around eating disorders to
shine the light on these deadly
illnesses dispel misinformation
and connect people with the
support they need recovery I
respectfully ask for your aye
vote thank you center died
members discussion or debate
on the floor last call for
discussion or debate on the
floor xenon Mrs sector
can you please call the roll
Allen by Archuleta
I Atkins aye Bates
aye bill by Porges
I Bradford aye carrier
I Chiang aye Dodd
aye Dourado aye Galgiani
aye Glazer aye growth
aye Hertzberg aye hill
I wish so I thought of
I Jackson aye Jones
hi labor I'm McGuire
aye aye Mitchell aye Monning
by more lock I'm real
I Nielsen aye pan
aye Portantino aye Roth
aye Rubio I Skinner
aye stern stone
hi I'm Burke our county
by Wiener aye Wilk
aye hi thirty seven
no zero the resolution is
adopted senators were advancing
to -- and returning to motions
and resolutions this is the
time for a journey memories we
have for that have been advance
to the pro tem's office in
the majority leader's office
we're gonna start with senator
Galgiani good morning thank
you Mr chairman members I rise
to join in the memory of Todd
summers who was an activist
in the San Joaquin county
community -- since I was twenty
one years old when I first met
him he was a former president
of the end of the laci P. from
nineteen eighty six to nineteen
ninety two he at ten after
attending college he joined
the United States Air Force
during the Korean War before
being honorably discharged in
nineteen fifty five he also
served on the San Joaquin County
Board of education he leaves
behind his wife of thirty one
years two sisters for children
four step children nineteen
grandchildren and two great
grandchildren I ask that the
Senate please adjourn in his
memory Sir Galgiani thank
you for advancing and please
pass on our deep condolences
to the family members would
like to turn the floor over to
the Majority Leader Hertzberg
is it what about what
percentage center Hertzberg
thank you very much sure
Mister president I arise
today with a heavy heart that to
to commemorate the life of the
legendary Dodger pitcher
and long time resident of
committees I represent don
Newcombe -- I did
know him but I suspect a lot
of folks here on this floor
knew of him or knew him two
days ago on February nineteenth
he passed away at the age of
ninety two don Newcombe as many
know was one of the greatest
pitchers in Dodger history
over his ten year career in
the major leagues he recorded
a hundred and forty nine wins
one thousand one hundred and
twenty nine strikeouts twenty
four shutouts with in a total
of two thousand one hundred
and fifty four innings pitched
a body any was an extraordinary
trailblazer a Mister new come
in nineteen forty nine he was
signed by the Brooklyn Dodgers
and became the third African
American pitcher in the major
leagues of that year he was
among the first for African
American players ever to be
named and also to the all star
team along with Jackie Robinson
Roy Campanella and Larry Doby
and fifty six at the pinnacle
of his career he won both the
sci one of the young award
in the National League MVP award
and held an impressive record
of twenty seven wins seven
losses after his retirement
Mister Neukom remain deeply
involved the Dodge organization
as a director of community
affairs an adviser to the teams
teams German and remained
an avid fan de rarely rarely
did he missed a game that
the Dodgers were beating the
giants armed whatever they were
but you could tell about much of
a sports fan but I got a great
people live in the community
I represent but before he
passed I just want to share one
final thought he a don had a
the conversation a with the
LA with an LA times reporter
and yet in that conversation he
said I remember Jackie Jackie
Robinson calling me and Roy
together after we first signed
with the Dodgers don said Jackie
said that people are going to
hate us in abuse us and by
changing one letter in a word we
can make a difference he paused
for a moment and said bitter
just change the are you T.
Jackie said it we should fight
to be better not bitter and
sure enough that's what happened
don Newcombe is survived by
his wife Karen three children
don junior Kelly and Bret two
grand a children came in and
Ryan members please join me
in a joining in the memory
of the baseball legend an
American hero a don Newcombe
thank you so much miss Majority
Leader enter Bradford on this
item Sir yes Mister president I
join my colleague from the San
Fernando Valley and journeyed
in the memory of don Newcombe
aye individual that I did now --
individual that a French it was
developed not through baseball
but through golf all
we shared many rounds of golf at
Chester watching golf course and
he was a giant of a man but more
so age gentle man and
all aspects I always referred
to him as Mr new come in he'd
always say call me don or the
big new but I was always Mister
new come to me but he shared
more about life than anything
else and here's individual who
should be in the hall of fame
if it's not for his substance
abuse that he didn't run from
-- that prevented him from
going to the hall of fame a
career as soon Hertzberg stated
it was only ten years in the
making are two of those were
interrupted for military service
and once returning back from
military service he was
quite upset at the fact
that he still could not stay
in the hotels wood is white
colleagues and so he and Jackie
Robinson and -- Roy Campanella
decided one day we're going
to get off the bus and we're
going into this white hotel
we're going to stay here the
manager came down he says
you can stay here log you
don't swim in the pool but
he was a trail blazer
and civil rights in many
ways Dr Martin Luther king
had a conversation shortly
before his assassination any
thank don Newcombe usage you
made my good odd journey
and civil rights any quality
that much easier by what
you did in baseball baseball
was opportunity to bring folks
together and mark the to king
appreciated his contributions
there Mister Nichols spent the
last fifty four years of his
life helping other video at
individuals whether they were
in sports entertainment industry
or just regular everyday folks
deal with substance abuse add
dot was his passion that's what
he spent by digital lots fifty
four years of his life doing
so he was the first black case
a picture that won twenty games
and since you first on that
sixty seven years ago only
a hundred and ninety five
people have won twenty games
or more and he's not was
the first player to win MVP
cy young and rookie of the
year and president Barack
Obama also stated that
Mr Neukom is someone who helped
America become what it is and
that he would not be here today
if it wasn't for the leadership
of Jackie Robinson and that of
Don Neukom so he was a powerful
man both on and off the field
and I have so we adjourn in his
memory thank you very much
center Bradford grateful you
came forward and that center
Glazer would you like to be
a common on the side of no
right members where
I anyone else on Mister
Neukom senator
Glazers the floors are Sir
thank you Mister president
members -- many of you know my
wife Melba and I'm sad to tell
you today that her mother --
passed away a few days ago --
Margarita le Fuente must
corollas we refer to her as Nina
she had a very interesting life
she left Cuba nineteen fifty
six with her husband Martin
and nothing -- except for what
the clothes on her back as she
carved out a new life in America
first in Miami later moving to
California becoming a citizen --
and living in eagle rock raising
five five beautiful daughters
in Maryland Melba or it's
-- and beer to she
was preceded in death by her
husband Martin -- in addition
to her wonderful daughters
-- son in laws grant Abramson
and and Richard low -- she had
four grandchildren aerial Alex
Diego and Emilio who she adored
and brought great a love to her
life she was a kind and loving
woman great sense of humor
wonderful cook and --
always had a sparkle in her deep
blue eyes for that son in law
who would say and do something a
little silly so with that
members I'd thank you for a
adjourning in her wonderful
memory NY map nay -- she
rest in peace thank you
so much center Glazer earn can
imagine the grief that families
going through at this time
please accept our condolences
members we would like to turn
the floor over to center Grove
good morning good morning thank
you Mister president members
many people know Bakersfield
because of its many acres
of orchards and vineyards a
Buck Owens and Merle Haggard
doors ice cream ice milk and
their famous candy chews but
anyone who has lived in Baker
so long enough also remembers
me six transmission founded
owned and operated by my
constituent Herald Eugene music
passed away on Sunday February
seventeenth weeks before his
eighty sixth birthday girl
was born to Arthur and pearl
music of Childress Texas and
was a child of the decibel
days surviving several life
threatening events before
eventually made his way to
California where he would
spend the rest of his life
as a businessman providing
jobs to our community and
servicing most of Bakersfield
transmission work he spent
the rest of his life here in in
Baker is filled with the sweet
heart in the level of his life
Lorraine a marriage that lasted
sixty eight wonderful years
though they endured a lot of
hardship and toil to realize
the California dream they also
experienced abundance of joy
happiness and pride a purchase
a persistent fishermen and even
a better storyteller with a
joke every moment on his lips
Herald was also very serious
at the times when he said that
the rain was the catch of his
life Herald in the rain live
-- were hardly ever part during
the seven decades that they
jointly ran their business
raise their four children Randy
Lorene nail Laurie Terry and
Dan and they'd doted on there
eighteen grandchildren and their
thirty nine great grandchildren
and still counting he was
also uncle Herald to numerous
nieces and nephews and boss to
anyone who knew him or even I
worked at me six transmission
imprecision transmission parts
up until nineteen ninety nine
beyond his family in business
Herald love the lord and he
served faithfully is a member
of the church of Jesus Christ
of latter day saints in many
capacities as a bishop a
missionary a stake patriarch in
a temple sealer he taught his
posterity and frankly anyone
who would listen the importance
of loving and serving others
through his consistent example
of crisis like charity he often
according one of his favorite
scripture scriptures from the
book of Mormon when we're in the
service of our fellow beings we
are only in the service of god
he never ran into a stranger any
had friends everywhere he went
he left a legacy of hard work
left for the lord his family
solidarity in the community
that he served all of his life
I send my condolences to the
left as his life Lorraine and is
incredible posterity as they lay
him to rest this Sunday and ask
the Senate to turn in his memory
today senator thank you so much
for advancing the journey memory
please pass on our condolences
senators those are journal
memories for Thursday the
twenty first of February we'd
like to be to do announcements
of committee action madam
budget chair would you like
to be able to announce the
committee meeting thank very
much Mister president a members
of the budget fiscal review
committee we will commence
today's budget hearing at ten
AM in room forty two oh three
thank you you made about a chair
members without further do
there is no other business
protein Machen's the desk is
clear Mister president thank
you colleagues thank you for
very productive weekly will
reconvene on Monday at two PM
have a wonderful weekend thank
you mayor pro tem the Senate
will be in recess until three
thirty PM at which time the
journey motion will will be
made we'll reconvene Monday at
two PM budget committee members
room forty two oh three
at ten AM have good we can